Some pictures of your dad there, Stephen Hawking.
He died this year in March.
He did. He died on the 14th of March,
which is actually the birthday of Albert Einstein,
which is quite remarkable because he was born on the anniversary of the death of
Galileo, Galileo, Galileo, the great Italian astronomer.
And he died on the birthday of Albert Einstein.
And it was like this final flourish. Um,
it was just another extraordinary,
another extraordinary fact about him.
He, he, he got,
he got to live more than 50 years more than the
doctors predicted.
That's right.
He was given an early and devastating prognosis around age
20. He was told that he would only live for a couple of years,
that he had motor neuron disease and that effectively his life was over.
And I think he was, he was understandably extremely depressed and very saddened,
but then he sort of pulled themselves together. He met my mother,
they fell in love. They decided to get married.
He happened upon an idea for his PhD thesis and he obviously
decided like, right, I'm going to do this whatever time I have left,
I'm going to make the most of it.
And of course he didn't know at that time it was going to be 50 years.
We didn't know none of us knew.
And yet he carried on making the most of every single day that he had.
Let's start with. And tell me, tell me about that day when he passed away.
That's a very sad day. Um,
I actually had been living with my father since Christmas because I
wouldn't stay with him for Christmas.
And I was really only intending to stay for a few days. Um,
but I actually ended up moving in with him.
And so I lived with him until the end,
but I wasn't actually there I'd gone home for 24 hours and I was sort of really
devastated by that. I thought, but I wasn't there,
but this is a very common experience. A lot of people who've told me since then,
but very often, um, people can't let go when somebody they love is there.
They actually wait for that person to leave the room or go somewhere else. Um,
for, they feel they can slip away.
So I got a call very early in the morning to say
your father has died.
And that was just a very
impactful memory that I, I,
I will remember for forever that phone call the phone ringing,
picking it up, hearing those words, and then
getting out of bed, realizing there were things, you know, that,
that there's this shock being shocked and stunned, but still sort of realizing,
well, there are things I have to do. Um,
and I ended up calling a new birth to take me to Cambridge because I was sort of
discombobulated I'm in the wrong place. And the irony was all that time.
I remember with my father, I had been nipping home, you know,
I'd been popping home to sort of tidy up a post,
do whatever you do and empty the fridge. Um,
and I'd always packed my case. As soon as I got home,
I would unpack my case and repack it immediately,
so that I'd be ready to go if I needed to go straight back.
And that was the one time I hadn't. So I sort of blundered around,
pulling things out of drawers and shoving them on the front called, well,
I don't know what to do. And then got in a taxi and went.
Do you remember your last conversation?
I have a very vivid memory of the last time.
I feel that I actually spoke to my dad when he was still sitting up in his chair
before he became bedridden. And that, yeah, that was,
it's very strange to think back now because in some ways it feels like it was an
eternity ago. And in other times it just,
it feels like it almost hasn't happened because he's so omnipresent in a way,
you know, I still hear his voice. I still, we see pictures of him.
He is sort of with us, even though he's not.
So in a way it's not like he's gone.
I don't know whether that's a thing about grief of bereavement,
whether other people experience that,
but you have this feeling of presence like that, that person is still there.
And of course he'd be furious with me for saying that because that,
wasn't what he believed.
The tool. Sorry.
But did you talk about small things or big things or.
I mean, I think we were more normal than people ever gave us credit for.
So.
Conversations about the first three minutes after the big bang.
And then we talk about whether to get a Curry for taker, a takeaway,
go for dinner. I think people really got us at all ever.
I, I, I mean him,
him dying is it's it's, um, it's a shock for you, but it's,
uh, it's always as with people of, of his, uh, um,
what should I say magnitude it's it's, it's a worldliness as well.
That was one of the astonishing things was how quickly, how far, how,
how report and, and there's, there's this sort of extraordinary,
just this outpouring of affection that came from everywhere,
all around the world.
Suddenly we were being sent emails and messages and people were, uh,
WhatsApping me, uh, sort of cartoons that had come out in, in,
in the newspaper in South Africa that day featuring him.
And they were also beautiful, you know,
they were so sweet and they were so funny and so sad and so
poignant. And like, I think, um, that, that tweet from Barack Obama, you know,
I hope you're having fun up there among the stars, you know,
that still brings a tear to my eye every time I think about it.
So that I think was just extraordinary.
Tell me about the funeral. That was, that was, that was not a small funeral.
No, I'd never organized a funeral before.
And I just had this overriding impression that this really wasn't the one to
start with.
It was quite.
A big deal. And I did think, Oh, I hope I haven't got this wrong. Um,
and that was tough because we knew that he had a lot of friends,
had a little bit, he had 37 first cousins.
He's part of a massive family who all obviously wanted to come and then bring
partners. And so,
and then all his colleagues and his friends and people from Cambridge. Um,
so just people wanted to come.
So I knew that the church would be full and we just still needed to hold it in,
um, the university church, because that's where academics,
distinguished academics at Cambridge university have their funerals.
My father was, he liked a bit of Palm print tradition. Oh, Oh,
Oh my goodness. Are you kidding? I mean, if we'd have had some sort of,
I don't know, some kind of nondescript panel room, thank you to be livid.
I mean, really,
I went through all that and you can't even give me a proper sendoff.
So I did feel that it was beholden on us to do it properly and to do it in,
in that way. And we had the most, somebody said to me afterwards,
they said that funeral was a template for somebody who wants a religious service
that is not even remotely religious. The reading was from Plato.
The Bible reading was read by Eddie Redmayne. Uh,
I think you have to have the Lord's prayer in a church service,
but we had it song and old church Slavonic. And I was like, yeah, no,
one's gonna realize so, and, and the,
the address was brilliantly given by the Dean of my father's college.
And she just really managed to talk about him, context of Plato,
of great discovery of inspiring humanity. Um, and,
and a lot of people left feeling very inspired and it was all quite solemn.
You know, we had lots of solar music and then right at the very end,
only the musical director, and I knew this was going to happen.
So the strains of ALGOL sorry, host, drifted away.
And then somebody started playing, fly me to the moon on the piano, you know,
the Frank Sinatra thing.
And he just started off very quietly and it got bigger and bigger until he was
doing full, kind of like this along the piano. And it just left.
Everyone said that was so him,
it was like that final kind of leave you with a smile.
[Inaudible] you grew up with him. Uh, and he was your dad.
And yet he was not the normal dad. He was a different dad.
Uh, when did you realize that he wasn't like all the dads?
Um, I remember being at primary school and drawing a picture of my parents.
You know, my family, as you do,
and everyone else was drawing pictures of their family. And I was like, okay,
that's my family. And I drew my down, sitting down. Right.
And everyone else had drawn that out, standing up. I remember going, Hmm,
that's funny. Why is my dad sitting down? And your dad is startling because,
you know, children draw those stick figures.
And so I had my mom and then I had my brother and then there was that,
and he was sitting down and he had this kind of blue square behind his head.
And one of my friends said, why is he got a blue square behind his head?
But of course it represented the wheelchair. And I just remember thinking, Oh,
that's kinda different. Um,
we had quite a sort of unusual household. Um,
one of my jobs was to answer the phone and that was really exciting, um,
because we were listed in the phone book.
And so I pick up the phone and someone would go,
I must speak to Stephen Hawking. And I'd be like, well, I'm sorry,
but he's in the, if I don't speak to him in the next 10 minutes,
the universe is going to explode.
Well, there we go.
I have a sort of,
I developed kind of a friendship with this man who would ring up and say he was
always at Newton from Japan.
I.
Was quite young. I was probably like about eight years old. And I would think,
you know, I really think if you were Isaac Newton,
you'd understand the time difference between Tokyo and London,
because you call it really stupid hours.
And then he stopped calling. And I've worried about him ever since,
as to what happened to him, who knows.
So all these kinds of strange things happened, which I thought were quite.
He was a genius.
But I didn't see him as that. Excuse my dad. So I was like, yeah,
you may say that, but you're my dad. And I'm like 16.
So I know way more than you do.
I remember actually saying too much when I was teenager, I was like, seriously,
dad, what would you know? Um,
You have to say it to him now. Come on.
I'm glad to hear this because not only normal dads,
he got it too. Yeah, yeah.
That's right. No, none of us think you're cool.
Um, he was a, of course, extremely physically challenged. Um,
how did that affect family life and daily life for you?
Well, I mean,
profound disability is a challenge and for the
person who experiences it and for the people around them.
And of course in those days, um, people were really not used to seeing, uh,
people with a disability out and about it. Wasn't kind of the done thing.
Like if you were disabled, you should be in a wheelchair being pushed,
preferably by a nurse, probably with like a tall rock over your knees. Um,
and you should be sort of suitably grateful to be allowed to be out and about.
And you shouldn't have any expectations of doing things.
Like my father would like drive his own electric wheelchair at great speed.
And then he'd go down the road, like the middle of the road in his wheelchair.
Um, and he wanted to go to restaurants and he'd want to do stuff.
You'd want to eat out.
He'd want to go anywhere that non-disabled person would go.
He thought he had a right to go. And so he was kind of a pioneer for that,
because now that's an expectation, you know, you think, well,
why wouldn't you let people go to any place that they want to go?
And now we have laws about access,
but those days you'd get somewhere and there'd be just a flight of stairs and
he'd be like, right. What do we do now? And that was tough. And.
Of course you have,
you have the people who's there and you have the people's stick,
tend not to stare. Yeah.
The staring people, please don't stare at people.
That is the, that is the key, right?
It is. It is. Um, I read recently about this,
this fabric that has led lights in, printed in it.
So you can't see that they're there,
but I just thought you could do it so that you had the t-shirt,
if you're wearing it and you'd be with a disabled person and someone,
the staring still goes on, by the way, someone, when they stay,
you could just flick a switch and it would come up in light saying,
stop staring.
That'd be so cool.
Really freak people out as well.
Cause you could then switch it off and they might think they'd imagined it.
He did. He react to it as much as the rest of, you know, he didn't care.
He didn't play it.
I mean, sometimes I think when there was a big change in my life.
So when I was growing up,
he wasn't famous in the way we think of him in those later
iconic years, um, he was a theoretical physicist.
He was well-known among physicists there. Not that many of them, you know,
so it was really after brief history of time that the whole kind of fame
pressure cookers things happened. Um, and he had ways of dealing with that.
You know, people would go.
Oh, look, isn't that, that guy that's that, Oh, you know that.
The guy,
the time guy it's like that Stephen Hawkins person and he'd immediately
say on his machine, he'd gone always be mistaken for that, man.
I'm really confused. We don't, we're not interested now.
So he is quite kid.
You know, and, and he had this thing.
If people barged in front of him to get to a lift,
he would have this other instant response that would then go,
I'm so sorry to find that your legs don't work, um,
which really put people in their place and they'd be like, Ooh, oops. Um,
so yeah, he was mad.
Humor was a great part of it.
All of us, you know, we all had to develop a very healthy sense of humor.
It had to be able to laugh when things got tough because they do, you know,
he was ill a lot. He had motor neuron disease.
It's a devastating condition that is still not very well understood.
When, when could you see his frustration, his, his,
uh, depression or sadness? Did you ever see that?
I don't think he was depressed.
I think he was resolutely robust and upbeat frustrated. Yes.
Because he'd wanted to do stuff and somebody, for reasons,
rightly or wrongly would sometimes say no, uh, no, Steven,
we're not going to take you down in a submarine.
Steven. We're not feeling.
Super confident about this space flight.
Yeah.
So those things didn't get done very well. Um, I mean,
he did say to me and this,
I still find very heartrending towards the end of his life. He said, um,
he felt lonely because he felt people didn't talk to him.
Um, as they would, he would have liked people to talk to him more,
but he thought people were put off by his disability and by his fame and people
used to say to me, I'd in front of myself. I'd, I'd love to talk to your dad,
but I don't know what to say. And I was like, well,
I would talk to your dad if I met him. So why don't you just talk to my dad?
You know, just say anything, talk about the weather took.
And I did have friends who were brilliant,
who just sit down with him and go and, and have like a question go, Stephen,
what's on your bucket list. And then just, and that was so nice.
And I love those friends, but during that.
That communication part, because first he could talk. Um,
and then till 1985. Yeah. But it got worse than that. And.
Up to 1985, his voice deteriorated, which is a thing in motor neuron disease.
Um, it just, the voice gets kind of scratchy and rusty. Um, but his,
his loss of voice was, um,
exacerbated because he had to have a jacket ostomy when he had pneumonia.
And so that means that you do lose the use of your voice box and that's when he
switched to computerized a synthetic voice.
And can you still remember his voice?
Um, it's funny. I thought I could,
and then I heard it the other day on a documentary. I mean,
and I was quite shocked actually, because I'd sort of forgotten about it,
you know,
it's so associated him with that very clear American.
Excellent. And that, that became his voice to me.
So it's the box. Yeah, the box. Yeah. My son was so naughty.
My son used to answer the phone and go, hello, this is stupid. Okay.
But he's very literal. I was like, okay, stop it.
Um, is it
perhaps not a fair question, but did he,
did it happen that he could use his limitations
to his advantage, but that was his whole thing.
Of course it is. Um,
well he did say to me once work out, you know, what you,
if you have something that you other people think is a disadvantage, you must,
you must make it into your advantage. Um,
so he was quite sort of cheeky, you know, and he obviously thought, well,
I'm in a wheelchair, so I'm going to make the best of it. Um, yeah,
I absolutely,
that was his whole thing was to take a limitation and defy it and he took great
ought to transcend it. So he took a lot of pleasure in that. I think.
It could be also some big because sometimes because of this machine,
he took awhile before he said something. Yes. Was that,
do you suspect that sometimes was on purpose that he, he,
he used the poem because it gave him a bit of power English. Yes.
Yes. It, it, it certainly, but I think if you'd asked him,
what would you prefer?
Would you like to have that pause or would you like to be able to communicate
freely here to swap to in a heartbeat?
Because he was really a communicator that he was, he wasn't, and that was,
I suppose, the frustration for me,
because I always felt like there's so much more to say,
and I don't know if we're going to have time to say it all. And that was, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, you, you,
you have many years without so much contact with him.
Yes. We went our separate ways at one point, which is,
I think fairly normal for family thing for families to do.
I saw him through that time, but not very often.
And perhaps not in such a close fashion as we ended up, not,
not as closely as we ended up what brought you back together? Well, um, I, uh,
moved as, you know, the twists and turns that life takes. And I,
to my brother to my own surprise actually found myself living in Cambridge with
my son, um, as a single parent. And, uh,
my son has autism and my parents were both really keen to be supportive.
And so that was actually amazing because, uh,
my dad wanted to be involved in my son's life. My son sort of adored him.
He thought having a granddad with wheels was coolest thing anybody could ever
have. He was like a big fan of Thomas, the tank engine at the time book,
his granddad as a sort of alternative tank engine kids. Um,
and so we sort of naturally we started, but, you know, I was just local.
I was just, I was just around the corner. So we started hanging out and I did,
um, I cooked with him a lot. Um, I never mastered his favorite dish,
which was a creme brulee, but he did eat his way through many really quite bad.
It's really nice, very sweetly. And so we, we sort of, we, we, you know, we,
so we started kind of just hanging out being family.
I went on a couple of trips with him,
which was a bit of an eye-opener because I hadn't been on a trip with him.
So I hadn't really understood it.
First hand the impact of his status as a superstar, he was, we went to,
I went to Hong Kong with him and that was just astonishing to me because we
would trail across Hong Kong by a press pack.
And we'd like be in this bar and we look forward and someone would say, where,
where are, where are we going? Where are we getting off? And you'd go,
we're getting off where all those people with cameras are standing.
Cause you'd know. Um, it was just, it sort of blew my mind anyway.
And then, um, we, my son had a birthday party and all his friends arrived.
And then my dad came and it was like, the magician had arrived.
Everyone was like, Oh, Oh, these kids were like, Ooh. I just thought that was,
I was really taken aback.
And one of his little friends just sauntered up to him and said, so Stephen,
what would happen to me if I fell in a black hole? And my dad said,
you'd be turned into spaghetti. And all the kids would deny too.
They thought this was hilarious, but they got it at some level.
They just understood what he had said. Um,
and all the parents were like here. I thought it was, they spaghetti.
I was like, you don't know what this is about. And so,
um, we decided to write a book about it because there's such a great question.
Like how would a boy fall in a black hole? What would he be doing?
How would he be just hanging out in space and how would we get him back?
And so we decided to write a fantasy novel, but make all the science real.
And this became a huge success. Now I've just the last book came out this year.
And the last book is kind of attribute to my father's ideas.
It takes a lot of the things he said about some of the fears he had about the
way the world was developing and it kind of illustrates them.
So it gives you a world of the future where some of my father's doc predictions
have actually come true.
And also, um, uh, the book, uh,
brief answers to big questions.
That is my father's last.
Book. Exactly. And you, you, you, you, you finished it in a way.
We, we, we, we finished it. Um,
it's very important sort of record of what he thought on a number of really
important topics.
And I think my thought was that he's going to be somebody who will be thought
about who will be talked about who will be, and people will talk.
And I just wanted him to have his own record, his own voice,
his own record of what he actually thought and said, what's your own theory.
They question, um,
that is a really tricky one because I think he was be very,
very proud to see the Watson side of black hole chapter because black holes that
was really, you know, his life's work,
black holes and the origins of the universe.
And he told me that was something he wants to be remembered for that that was
what he most wanted to be remembered for.
But I also think that the chapters on AI is very important. Um,
his thoughts on human survival on earth, because he was very,
he was very outspoken about climate change. Um, and also his thoughts on AI.
And he was one of the people who at a time when we were very,
everyone was very kind of blown away with the possibility of technology and this
kind of massive optimism like technology will fix everything.
He was one of the few people to say, well, hang on a minute,
let there's another side to this.
Let's just think about the impact on normal people, on people,
on their jobs, on their life. How is this actually going to work?
How do we make sure that when we have these super advanced technologies that we
don't leave people behind,
we don't leave people disenfranchised and lonely and with a feeling of
worthlessness because they haven't been able to keep up with a super-intelligent
machine. So I think that's a very important thing that he did.
Cause he would say these things and people would listen and there's been a
discernible change.
Um,
[inaudible] I just want to one more thing because when,
when people pass away, we, we w we're there with their things. I mean, we're,
we're left with their things. Um,
and some of them are meaningless and some might carry meaning and some might
carry emotional value. What do you, after him that carries emotional value?
Well, I said, um, of everything I said,
the thing I really want is the coffee grinder.
I don't really want that coffee grinder.
I was prepared to fight both my brothers for it,
especially cause I'd been living with my dad loved proper coffee.
And so the beans would be ground and this just very ordinary,
small plastic coffee grinder. But it just, I don't know,
the coffee was just the best coffee. Um, and so I said, I put my,
I staked my claim early on to my brothers. I was like,
you can have anything you like, but the coffee grinder is mine.
And they knew from the look in my eye that I meant it. No, no one,
no one challenged me on that.
What happened to his famous wheelchair? I mean, that's.
We have actually, we have quite a collection of wheelchairs.
We've almost got a historical collection of wheelchairs down the ages.
You can see the March of technology through wheelchairs.
So we have about at least eight wheelchairs from different periods of his life.
I find it very, I find the wheelchair too sad.
I can't look at it because it's missing.
Lucy. It's been wonderful to talk to you. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.